welcome to the science Asylum I Nick
lucid with what I found in the tool box
what a flashlight wonder what this
button does I'll turn it off give it off
behave this device seems simple enough
two double-a batteries a 3 volt light
bulb and some metal to complete the
circuit but how does that bulb make
light what even is light yeah we asked
the deep questions around here let's
take a closer look at that light bulb
inside the bulb there's a coiled
filament usually made of tungsten as it
heats up it starts to glow red then
orange yellow and finally white the
reason the filament heats up in the
first place is because it's a resistor
that means the filament takes energy
away from passing electrons and it's
atoms vibrate faster every time one
bumps into another they lose a little of
that energy as light and we get a
functioning flashlight light is created
whenever charges accelerate that means
whenever they speed up slow down or
change direction that's true whether
you're talking about flashlights or
radio towers or the x-ray machine that
the doctors or your microwave oven which
is partly why the idea of electrons
orbiting in atoms is totally ridiculous
the electrons would continuously lose
energy until the atom collapse so light
is just energy not exactly remember
energy doesn't just float around on its
own it has to be possessed by something
light is that something but what is it
exactly no rule every day stuff fits
into two categories waves or particles
this is a debate that is raged for
centuries so let's take it slow
possibility number one light is a wave
this was something proven by Thomas
Young in 1801 using diffraction when you
hear the word wave you probably think of
water waves not surprisingly that's
actually where the word wave comes from
but lots of things can wait you just
have to get matter to move back and
forth repeatedly if it happens in the
earth you call it an earthquake if it
happens in the air you call it sound for
light amplitude measures brightness and
frequency measures color but light
travels through empty space where there
isn't any matter that's because light
isn't a wave in matter it's an
electromagnetic wave electrical magnetic
fields are created by charges since
charges have been around since the
beginning of time so have those fields
and by default so is light light might
need matter to be created but it doesn't
need it to move around if that makes you
uncomfortable let's consider possibility
number two light is made of particles
this was an idea proposed by Isaac
Newton in the late 1600s and then
supported by the work of Max Planck and
Niels Bohr in the early 1900s
it's a pretty straightforward idea all
the tangible things we interact with
they're made of particles glass water
air even your own body so why would life
be any different we call the particles
of light photons how many photons there
are and a beam of light determines its
brightness more photons means brighter
light fewer photons means dimmer light
so which is it waves or particles both
photons are one of the many quantum
beasts that lurk at the microscopic
scale when we work with stuff down there
we have to let go of those kind of
distinctions those things that you
always hear being called particles
actually display properties of both
their particle waves even with photons
frequency still measures color photons
have frequency but I don't see any of
that weirdness happening around here
that's because this stuff is made of
tons of particle waves interaction
compels these particle waves to pick a
side that's why we never see it the only
difference between what we call matter
and what we call light is what side they
consistently choose most of the time
though you're not dealing with
individual photons you're dealing with a
whole beam full of them and calling
light a wave works just fine oh yeah
it's not fun is it
so what inanimate objects should we
think this deeply about next let us know
in the comments thanks for liking
sharing and subscribing and until next
time remember it's okay to be a little
crazy